We now continue the study of the
sum of a random number of
independent random variables.
We already figured out what is
the expected value of this
sum, and we found a fairly
simple answer.
When it comes to the variance,
however, it's pretty hard to
guess what the answer will be,
and it turns out that the
answer is not as simple.
So this is what we will
try to calculate now.
The way to proceed will be to
use the law of total variance,
which effectively breaks down
the problem by conditioning on
the value of the random
variable capital
N. So let us start.
We have already figured out that
if I tell you the value
of capital N, then the expected
value of the random
variable Y is just this number,
capital N, the number
of stores you are visiting,
times how much you are
spending in each one
of the stores.
Using this information, we can
now calculate this term, the
variance of the conditional
expectation.
What is it?
It's the variance of capital N
times the expected value of X.
Now, the expected value of X
is a constant, and when we
multiply a random variable with
a constant, what that
does to the variance is it
multiplies the variance with
the square of that constant.
And this gives us this term in
the law of total variance.
Let us now work towards
the second term.
If I tell you the number of
stores, then the random
variable Y is just
a sum of a given
number of random variables.
And as we discussed before, the
conditioning that we have
here may be eliminated because
these random variables are now
independent of this random
variable, capital N. Their
distribution does not change
based on this information, and
so we obtain the unconditional
variance.
Now, the unconditional variance
of a sum of n random
variables is just n times the
variance of each one of them,
which we denote with
this notation.
Now, let us take this equality,
which is an equality
between numbers, and it's true
for any particular choice of
little n, and turn it
into an equality
between random variables.
This is the random variable that
takes this specific value
when capital N is equal
to little n.
So this is a random variable
that takes this specific value
when capital N is equal to
little n, but this is also the
same as this random variable,
n times the variance of X,
because this random variable
takes this particular
numerical value when capital
N is equal to little n.
Now that we have an expression
for the conditional variance
as a random variable, we can
take the next step and
calculate the expected value of
the conditional variance.
The expected value of the
conditional variance is simply
the expected value of this
expression that we
calculated up here.
And now the variance of X is a
constant and can be pulled
outside the expectation,
which leaves us with
this expression here.
Now that we have calculated both
terms that go into the
law of total variance, we
can add these two terms.
We have one contribution from
here, this is this term, and
another contribution from here,
which is this term.
What this expression tells us
is that the variance of the
total amount that you spend,
which is a certain measure of
the amount of randomness in
how much you are spending
overall, this amount
of randomness
is due to two causes.
One cause is the randomness
that there is in how much
money you spend in any given
store, and that's captured by
the variance of X. It's the
variance of the distribution
of the amount of money that you
spend in a typical store.
But there is another source of
randomness, and that source of
randomness comes from the fact
that the number of stores
itself is random, and this gives
us this contribution to
the variance of Y.
By taking into account these two
sources of randomness, we
can figure out the overall
variance of the random
variable Y. As you can see, this
is a formula that would
be hard to guess by just
reasoning intuitively.
And so it's a demonstration of
the power of the law of the
total variance.